mademoiselle macky sall vie
abonne toi
non
oh
en
toi au moins tu m'écoutes tu sais que
dans le temps je faisais des vidéos à 10
millions de vues ouais ça a des limites
et tartelettes l'a dernièrement il ya un
petit film qui est sorti je sais pas si
vous en avez entendu parler et star wars
mais du coup si tu n'aimes pas heureux
je parlais playstation 4
je possède une photo et tout le monde
laïque est j'avais tellement d'amis sur
facebook que je refusais du monde
j'ai fait plein de fans était amie avec
tous les plus grands de youtube
puis un jour il est arrivé shakila
drummond que ça [ __ ] de tat
intellectuelle son physique de coton
tige saluer vivo je suis super content
de vous retrouver aujourd'hui je vous
parlais un truc c'est les rêves bizarres
je sais pas vous moi j'en fais tout le
temps pas plus tard qu'hier j'ai rêvé
d'une armée de canard avec jack sparrow
et barack obama qui était normalement
jamais rien dit et de ce qu'ils
racontaient en une vidéo tout le monde
l'adoré c'est qu'il arrive
regarde suis trop fan de ce que tu fais
et je connais toutes les vidéos un ami
si leur plaisir je supportais pas son
succès ça me rendait fou salut mes
petites tartelettes ge est unanime
ce serait pas un petit peu nu totalement
c'est hallucinant comme cellule belge
je me suis mis à perdre les pédales je
me suis enfoncé ouais ça lui les petites
tartelettes de merde
et ouais chier à la gueule tous autant
que vous êtes puis si vous n'êtes pas
content c'est qu'à vous faire partie des
le cul par jacky l'agrume ok si vous
savez ce que c'est c'est un [ __ ]
après ça j'ai commencé à me prendre des
pousses rouge dans la vraie vie
à commencer par ma copine mais tu te
fous de ma gueule c'est quoi ce bordel
guignols partie
mais tu sais ce que c'est le plus dur
le plus dur
c'est être regardé sans jamais hôtel à
mon petit boss d'amour ça me fait
plaisir de voir 28 cents aujourd'hui mon
avion au pas très fort tu sais monsieur
un petit partage non pas grave
aujourd'hui ça fait combien de temps que
tu t'es pas connecté je joue je sais
plus trois jours peut-être m'en donnait
dix lignes dans un ciel blog mais le
topix était comment faire un rond de
serviette
alors je vais pas aller bien loin avec
ça mademoiselle n'auriez pas un pouce
ainsi arte un petit fin petit coeur je
suis fatigué j'en peux plus tu
connaîtrais pas un endroit où vous
pourrez m'héberger jockey mais tout ce
que je peux faire
malheureusement j'ai pas grand chose en
ce moment à j'ai un compte linkedin
oh non non non je touche pas ça mais si
celle ci a ouai ouai c'est fou c'est
bien ça me faire du bien ça
allez
tu laisses françois mengin jours merci
mon petit oiseau
et oublie pas de me tailler les gens
l'oublient souvent
a fait quoi cette guerre jojo fait ce
sens comment tu connais mon toit j'étais
fan de vous c'est grâce à vous si je
fais des vidéos de personnes les fans de
moi aujourd'hui il ya plus de jojo c'est
fini tout ça aujourd'hui c'est claude au
clos ont fait les audois lé partage
abonne toi ou post une chose attendez
suivent jean foot entendu le voilà
j'ai combien d'abonnés d'après vous toi
3 millions au minimum plus
non beaucoup moins manger 3000 abonnés
allez bon courage aux charges contre m
c'est là que ça lâche aussi
m
oh
salut mes petites tartelettes
il avait déjà pris le métro non parce
que moi il ya deux trois trucs qui
m'énervent un petit peu les honneurs non
mais sérieux faut faire deux mètres pour
que ça sente bon je voulais vous dire
merci parce que vous êtes déjà 12 à
regarder ce que je fais et ça ça ça met
du chauffage au palpitant ça fait
vraiment plaisir et ça me donne envie de
continuer alors merci merci beaucoup la
voient dans le métro